Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Moco-chan.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Is it really starting?
It's starting!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 28th episode, Ruffians!
I started off a bit different, though.
What are you talking about?
Moco-chan.
It's normal.
Fully normal.
All good.
Right, Ruffians?
This is how it always is.
Well, Ruffians, if it's your first time joining us in real time, or maybe not in real time, either is fine, but to explain a little about FUWAMOCO Morning, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.k.a.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us,
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
What do we have for today?
Was Pero seen around again?
It'd be weird if... Oh, he was!
Let's see!
Why was Pero seen this time?
De-den!
That's a smile.
Good smile!
Right!
But isn't this Doggie of the Day?
No...
See, there's Pero.
This is where Pero is.
He's kind of gotten himself into a situation.
He's made a new friend, right?
You know they're playing together, right?
Ruffians playing.
Playing.
Pero likes to get chewed on!
You think he likes that?
Explain!
You know, he doesn't look like he hates it really, right?
Wow, he's inside of the sweet chew toy!
It kinda looks like a chocolate korone, right?
And Pero's a chocolate!
Yeah.
I guess I can see that.
Oh, but I guess this doggy likes to eat the korone from the tip, huh?
What about you, Mococo?
Do you eat the korone from the tip or the face?
I feel like I have to sneeze.
Answer the question, Moco-chan!
Ruffians, how about you answer for me?
Do you eat the korone from the face?
Or from the tip?
Korone is always sort of chocolate inside, so... I have a classic Korone.
Chuu chuu chuu.
Class 2.
And for Pero though, I don't really know if... If he makes this yummy.
If he makes it not so yummy.
I don't even know if this red chewy thing... Does it taste good?
Ruffians, we definitely haven't chewed on it before, so...
We're demon dogs, thank you.
Yes.
We're not dogs.
No.
But, uh, hopefully it tastes good.
Hopefully Pero makes it taste better.
Yeah.
I don't know.
BAU BAU!
I would rather have custard.
Yeah, not the Pero filling.
Yeah.
No, no.
Custard.
Thank you!
Ruffians, please let us know if you see Pero around again, okay?
You can let us know with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Oh, it feels like that was the Doggie of the Day.
So cute!
That smile!
When was it?
I know!
Yesterday!
I mentioned it during our pair social stream last night, but...
I had a strange dream, right?
Oh, it's been a long time since we had a dream to share with the Ruffians.
I feel like I keep on forgetting, but... I remember this one.
Okay, it wasn't really all that interesting, but... It was a bit more strange and unsettling.
Unsettling?
I don't know, it's not that important.
But did you want to hear it?
Not violent.
Not violent dream.
No.
So, in my dream, I was cleaning and dusting our place and when I tried to reach a really high up area in the curtains, right?
Because you know when you're dusting you have to go up high too, right?
So, for some reason I bumped my head on this top part of the curtains that was like protected by a hard cover or a wood cover or something.
It wasn't that bad of a bump, but...
Okay, that's good.
But there was lots of dust and junk that got all over my head and my ears.
So I was panicking because I wasn't really sure what was in the massive layer of junk and gross stuff.
I was trying to get it off my head.
But no matter how much I tried to brush it off, just more dust and cobwebs would fall off.
Just more dust, more cobwebs, more dust, more cobwebs.
Yeah.
I was really worried because I thought maybe there might be spiders and maybe they might get my ears.
But I was also worried because I thought, I can't see the Ruffians like this!
And then the dream ended.
Strange, huh?
I thought it ended like a happy dream.
I woke up.
But it's a good thing because it was just a dream, yeah.
Right, right.
No spiders in your ears, yeah.
You can see the Ruffians right now.
Ears are nice and clean.
Oh good.
Wonder what it means?
Don't look into it!
It's just a dream, there's lots of them.
It's not a scary dream, it's just unsettling.
Sounds like a nightmare!
It was just a dream.
Yup.
You wanted to hear it.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for sharing, Moco-chan.
You're welcome.
Do we have some happy news?
I think so.
You know, Ruffians, last time we kind of inadvertently made a misunderstanding for ourselves, right?
But,
This time, look, Ruffians!
We did it!
There haven't been any more misunderstandings!
Maybe we're improving, Moco-chan.
I think we are.
This means October is starting off very nice!
Yay!
Good start to October, right?
Hopefully this can be a mostly misunderstanding brief.
FUWAMOCTOBER!
FUWAMOCTOBER.
What do you say?
What do you mean, Ruffians?
You did it, thank you.
We did it together.
Yeah.
But October already started?
It just started.
Yeah.
Just a start.
We're not talking about all of October.
It'd be nice if all of October would be like, that would be a lot of days without misunderstanding.
Can we keep it for the whole month?
Can we?
What do you think, Ruffians?
We're on a good track.
Good job.
Nope.
Nope with the period.
Ignore it.
Probably not.
BAU BAU!
Thanks for the positivity, Ruffians.
Well, it's not just that though.
Ruffians, we have a bit of a confession to make.
Do we?
A little bit, Moco-chan.
You know...
You know, recently, Ruffians, we've been trying to change our Twitter usage so, you know, that we can connect a bit more closely to you.
Yeah.
Have you noticed?
But, I don't know, I kind of feel that maybe it's taking a turn for the worse?
Because, uh... Moco-chan, Moco-chan, you have something to say, right?
Do I?
Something to confess!
I guess.
Maybe.
I guess sometimes when we tweet, of course, I'll read all your responses.
Thank you.
Yeah, thank you.
But sometimes, it just makes me a little bit more curious, you know?
So then, I get curious.
And I go to the profile of Ruffians who just tweeted back at us.
And I look at who they're following.
Just to see, like, who they're interested in, right?
You know, I'm just curious.
Just curious.
You know, sometimes I see a lot of cute girls and I think... Sometimes, good taste.
Sometimes,
Questionable.
And then I go over to the responses!
Like anyone normal.
And I see them chatting with other Ruffians!
And it makes me really happy, yeah.
I see that a lot too.
Ruffian.
You know, we talked about it before, but we're really happy to see you getting along all together.
It makes me feel like I want to work even harder too.
Right!
Be happy together, okay?
And you know, and then I just go over to the likes and I think... Hmm...
Is this a way to connect with you better?
Moco-chan.
I don't know.
I guess.
It's not really a confession, just sort of like a thought.
You know?
Sort of thing.
I guess.
Yeah!
Well, we confessed!
Now you know, Ruffians!
No!
This is how we're using Twitter now.
Stop it!
Enjoy it!
There's a lot of different ways to use social media, right?
That's one of the ways we will do it.
BAU BAU!
I think this is kind of happy.
Is it kind of happy?
Has FUWAMOCO Morning not been happy up until now?
I don't know, but Ruffians!
You know how at the end of every FUWAMOCO Morning, there are a handful of special Ruffians who are chosen to get their dreams better, right?
Right!
Wow!
We figured that there are probably a lot of Ruffians that want to be a special Ruffian of the day too, right?
Alright, so we thought maybe we can have a bit of a battle play with you and share some more strategic tips on how maybe you can raise your chances of being chosen.
Yeah!
Well, Ruffians, what do you think?
I mean, Ruffians have their own strategies.
Well, from FUWAMOCO!
Yeah, timing and luck is a huge part of it.
But also having a name that's rather easy and simple to read in a glance, I think is...
A big part of it too.
Yeah, right.
Something that's long and kind of difficult to read really, really quickly might not be the best.
Yeah, like even though it may be easy, things like maybe FUWAMOCO Ruffian 2023, it might be a bit difficult to just read at a glance, you know?
We also want to make sure that we pronounce your name as correctly as possible, so if you think maybe we might have a hard time with it, that's something too.
I see a lot of Ruffians saying they're gonna change their name.
But we know your name now.
But you know, we're doing our best.
Pronunciation's important.
We want to make sure that you understand that we called out your name.
If we say it a bit far away, then that's going to be disappointing.
We sometimes fumble names so hard.
We do.
I also store a name in my head once I find one.
And until I have a moment to it, so I can say it.
Good luck, Ruffians!
Happy BAU BAUing!
I'm sure that one day you can become a special Ruffian of the FUWAMOCO Morning, but...
I want you to also remember that you're always the special Ruffian in our hearts.
It's just a silly bonus thing, okay?
So don't be sad if you can't make the special Ruffian.
It's just a silly bonus, okay?
And yeah, if you have a long last name, don't worry about it, okay?
We'll probably just pick the first name.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU
Good luck with your driving exam.
You thought I wouldn't see that, huh?
BAU BAU!
Speaking of special Ruffians.
Ruffians!
RuffianS!
We actually received something very special from you, the other day.
We got a present.
We saw it on Twitter!
I wonder why.
Here we take a look at FUWAMOCO-chan.
You know, Ruffians, it seems like a bunch of you gathered all together to do something very special!
To sing our original introduction to Lifetime Showtime together as a group!
This is from Ruffian 5000 who uploaded it.
We're so happy!
Let's listen, let's listen!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Use your ears, okay Ruffians?
Okay, here we go!
That's not you, that's me.
I'm Moco-chan.
Bye kawaii!
It's showtime, it's showtime.
I'm ready!
Oh, here it comes.
It's a bit different, ready?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Very precious and unique to you, so you can be really nervous when singing.
You know, especially to record it and then have it heard by others.
Especially when maybe you're still new to singing, too.
It really means a ton to us.
Thank you!
I know you worked all together to make something for us.
We really...
Thank you, Ruffians!
Moco-chan's part, right?
Good job!
Don't wait, don't wait.
It's a lot of courage needed to do that.
A lot of courage, a lot of passion.
All Ruffians are voice haters!
Thank you, Ruffians!
We're really happy to be able to hear your voices.
It was wonderful.
BAU BAU!
Such a happy present, the best present.
Thank you, Ruffians!
I guess the Ruffians have been nice today.
Extra nice, right?
Nice today.
You know, I guess Wednesdays can be a bit rough.
I wanted to say something!
Hey!
It's me, Mococo!
And you know what this means!
Yeah!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And this time, you're gonna hear from me, Mococo!
You are still sleepy, are you?
You're awake, right?
Oh, you want five more minutes?
Okay, that's fine.
If those five minutes mean that you'll have that much more energy to take on today, that's fine!
Don't be too hard on yourself for it.
It's Wednesday!
It's okay to give yourself a little bit of wiggle room on things.
Not everything needs to be perfect, okay?
No matter what, it'll be okay!
You can do the scary thing.
You can get over it!
It can be productive, even if it's just a bit, and not as much as maybe you had hoped.
Okay?
Let's take as many steps as we can together today.
Just keep looking forward.
And before you know it, we'll be somewhere new and amazing all together!
You can do it!
We believe in you.
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Wise words from Moco-chan, huh?
I'm always wise.
BAU MOCO-CHAN!
Shall we head to our regular quarters?
Oh, Doggie of the Day!
It's Griffin!
Griffin's the Doggie of the Day!
He doesn't look like a griffin, he looks like a doggy.
Really?
Well, I don't even know.
I think Griffin may be tiny, but he's very dignified.
I feel like the name Griffin really suits him.
You don't think so, Moco-chan?
He's like a... a griffin nugget.
A griffin nugget?
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know, but his bark is really big too.
I feel like...
I like his nose.
Ah, his nose?
What are you gonna do to that, Moco-chan?
I'm gonna boop it.
I kinda wanna touch the little underneath the chin.
Is that his beard?
The beard!
You wanna touch the beard!
I wanna touch Griffin's beard!
What's this Griffin's big BAU BAU sound like?
BAU BAU!
I think that kind of BAU BAU would be really well because you know Griffin is wild and tiny which is like good to be able to get all the mean people around you.
The mean people that want to hurt your smile to get them to drop their guard and get them scared.
You'd be scared if you heard something like BAU BAU!
Right?
Are you gonna... Are you gonna...
Griffin's just good at his job.
I'm gonna give Griffin something to BAU BAU at.
But you know, I think Griffin's very happy to be able to protect you to be able to give a loud BAU BAU.
Because that means that Griffin now gets it all to himself.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And for today!
Did a Ruffian go on a nice walk?
I should hope.
You should hope.
The weather's not the nicest maybe, but let's see!
Today I went on a walk.
Where did we go?
De-den!
A river?
Today I walked by the river in the rain.
I got wet.
Extra wet.
Let's...
I think that one of them really were fussy.
I love it when it's soaked on.
It's confusing.
Are you soaked by the rain, the river, or Moco-chan's knee?
Please make sure that you don't get wet or anything because it'd be really bad if you caught a cold.
But you know we're proud of you!
Even though maybe it's not the nicest.
Yeah, we find it
It's so hard to go out on a walk on rainy days.
We don't want to become wet dogs, you know.
That will never happen.
We're good people.
But we hope you had lots of fun.
Maybe you spotted some cool fish or animals too.
Or raindrops.
That too.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Do we have a question from a Ruffian?
Ruffian boys have such good questions.
I know, right?
It's tricky.
We have... De-den!
BAU BAU!
What is a typical FUWAMOCO morning routine?
I don't... Ah, FUWAMOCO morning... Ah, there's not a cap.
I get it, I get it.
I don't have much of a routine, so I was wondering what is most important for you girls in the time from when you wake up to when you start the day off.
Also, this is extremely important.
What's the shampoo you use?
Is that extremely important?
FUWAMOCO's morning routine, right?
No, FUWAMOCO morning routine.
Which one?
I think if it was FUWAMOCO morning routine, then that's like, morning should be capitalized, right?
FUWAMOCO's apostrophe S morning routine versus FUWAMOCO morning routine.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
Day off?
Really?
I'm waiting.
When we wake up, we do some stretches.
We have breakfast while, you know, watching some simple, happy, educational, maybe Japanese TV.
Japanese TV stuff.
And then we get responding on some messages and working on homework while preparing.
For whatever stream we have coming up next, you know.
No, not drinking shampoo, no.
That's not part of the morning routine.
But some days are a bit sleepier than others, you know.
Yeah, somewhere in the day though, we also like to go for a nice walk too, but there's also other days that no matter how beautiful it is, we're just too busy and we can't get outside.
Is this a morning routine?
Oh, this is a full day routine.
Is that okay?
It's okay!
Yeah.
But yeah, yesterday was one of those days where we just couldn't get out either.
But, uh,
After we finish our evening session or bedtime, we like to both take baths to calm down and then also we can kind of respond to messages too.
Do more stretches, that's a nice start.
Try to sleep.
Get to sleep from there.
I feel like we're very lucky that it's rather simple.
Simple.
Some Ruffians have a much more busy daily routine going on.
But as for shampoo though, it's an extremely important question, right?
We recently changed to a different demon- a guard dog shampoo.
Yeah, it was recommended.
It was.
But it's a bit expensive, so... You know, I thought about it for a long time and then I decided.
No.
But as for the scent, it just smells nice.
Yeah.
I don't know what it smells like.
It smells nice though.
It smells nice.
Nice scent.
Wait, dog, no!
It's nice scent.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the question!
I love it when things are sent in nicely.
FUWAMOCO-chan, let's take a look at our next team before the time runs out here.
Our next team is... De-den!
It's a busy day.
We're streaming twice more after this.
Today.
We'll be collabing with some of our EN Senpai and element members in a game called
Party animals.
That's us.
Yeah, that's us.
We'll have to run and punch and grab and try to stay top dog amongst all the other animals.
Moco-chan, let's make sure that we show our senpai all the respect that they deserve, okay?
With punches.
We have punches!
Respect!
And after that, we're gonna be beginning our journey in Resident Evil 4 Remake!
It looks really, really scary, but we'll do our best.
We have weapons, right?
And make sure you're logged into...
So it is maybe any younger Ruffians that maybe you can just join us for Party Animals and we'll see you next time right for Suica Game!
But Ruffians that are old enough, make sure you're logged in, okay?
It's a warning.
Oh, a warning.
A warning.
What's gonna happen if the Ruffians are voted?
Can't watch.
That's true.
That sounds pretty bad.
BAU BAU!
We're going to sing whatever songs we feel like!
Whatever songs we can sing.
Not an archive.
Archive.
FUWAMOCO Rock n' Rawr Party is always archived unless we say so.
But this time we're gonna challenge ourselves to sing some new songs too, right Moco-chan?
But also other songs too.
You have to join us for lots more BAUing deshita!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
We shared some strategies.
Now's the time!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Rinsan!
BAU BAU!
Azurillac!
Buku's!
BAU BAU!
Yum!
Dropkicking Team.
BAU BAU!
Beastmode.
Umeshisou.
BAU BAU!
Morma.
Dragon Warrior.
BAU BAU!
The Cat.
Cough Drop.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!